the second largest bank failure in U.S
history just occurred First Republic
Bank was seized by regulators and its
assets were sold to JP Morgan the news
this morning is that JP Morgan is
acquiring First Republic directly from
the FDIC which seized and immediately
sold the faltering Bank this transaction
the result of a competitive bidding
process at least according to the FDIC
and JP Morgan includes a majority of
first Republic's assets including 173
billion dollars in loans and 30 billion
dollars in Securities this is on top of
three other large bank failures in the
last couple of weeks in fact three of
the four largest bank failures in U.S
history have occurred over the last two
months there was many people who thought
that the banking crisis was over but it
may just be beginning now though it's
interesting about First Republic Bank is
that it didn't happen overnight if we go
back and we look at Silicon Valley Bank
that happened in less than 36 hours and
then by the end of that weekend
Signature Bank was also taken into
receivership but what we are seeing here
with First Republic Bank is that they
not only had weeks and weeks to try to
fix some of the issues but also number
of the big Banks put more than 30
billion dollars in to try to help First
Republic Bank become more stable
all of that help and all of that time
wasn't able to save First Republic Bank
the second thing is that not only is the
magnitude of the problem a big big issue
but also this comes after the Federal
Reserve the FDIC the OCC and other
Regulators around the country created
all sorts of different systems and
programs whether it be lending programs
Discount Windows or others to try to
stem some of the problems from this
banking crisis
not only did First Republic Bank have
time not only did they have support from
the big Banks but they also had support
from the government and it still
couldn't save them now one other area
that I'm paying attention to right now
is that Warren Buffett and Charlie
Munger they aren't acting as We Know by
looking at their portfolio and watching
interviews of them from over the years
they love Banks and they love Financial
Services if there were banks that were
in trouble and those two thought that
they were great assets that they could
hold for a long time they'd be acting
and so the silence coming out of Omaha
is deafening if Charlie Munger and
Warren Buffett aren't buying right now
it tells you one of two things either
they think these assets are bad and they
don't want to own them or they think
that prices are going to go much lower
and they'll have a chance to make
purchases then
either way keep watching Omaha and
Berkshire Hathaway until they act the
problem may not be over another thing to
keep in mind is that if First Republic
Bank has gone down alongside silvergate
Silicon Valley Bank and Signature Bank
you would think that the government
would step in and make sure there was no
other Banks Under Pressure but now we
are seeing multiple other Regional Banks
their stocks have sold off more than 50
percent and people are becoming quite
antsy they're pulling their deposits and
they're moving to the larger and larger
Banks if that continues there's likely
to be more bank failures in the near
future
now of course these Banks it's been well
documented that they have all sorts of
treasuries and bonds that are trading
underwater and so if they're forced to
liquidate them they could wipe out their
equity and ultimately be insolvent but
on top of that there's another problem
that is brewing Charlie Munger actually
called it out
the commercial real estate loan books on
these Banks they're in trouble as well
there currently is a building in San
Francisco that previously was valued and
more than 300 million dollars and now
there are all sorts of bids coming in
for it for 60 to 80 percent off that
previous valuation now why would there
be bids that are 60 to 80 percent lower
it's because the building's sitting
there it's basically empty commercial
real estate has been torpedoed by remote
work and people wanting to live in
better places than packed in some of
these urban areas where crime or other
issues are running rampant and so if
you're a bank and you're lending against
an asset that you thought was worth 300
million dollars but it ends up being
worth 80 percent less your loans in bad
shape and so although there's things
like treasuries that eventually will get
paid out on par those commercial loans
it would take forever for the US
government to go in and underwrite every
single loan and understand what the true
value is that call causes complexity and
challenges for banks because yes the
government may be able to take some of
their fixed income and some of those
treasuries and bonds but I don't see a
world where they're going to start
taking commercial real estate loans and
say to the banks don't worry you can
offload your risk to us and we'll simply
give you one dollar at par value that'd
be wild but maybe I'm naive maybe we
shouldn't Ever Say Never the last thing
I'll say about the current banking
crisis and the second largest bank
failure in U.S history is this had
nothing to do with crypto previously
critics of the crypto industry they
blamed Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies for
the failures of silvergate Silicon
Valley Bank and signature but now with
First Republic Bank there's no one
trying to make that argument and so
people must wake up they must realize
that there was a banking issue not a
crypto issue at play as we continue to
move forward over the coming months one
thing to pay attention to is a looming
recession someone like Stanley
druckenmiller who's compounded capital
for over 30 years at 30 percent
he's short the dollar and he believes
that there's going to be a recession
that there's going to be a devaluation
of the currency and a return back to
loose monetary policy I'd say the one
area where I I feel reasonably
comfortable in is I'm sure at the United
States dollar currency Trends tend to
run at least two or three years we had a
long one here over 10 trillion something
like 13 trillion came into the US dollar
during the previous decade I will say
full disclosure I missed the dollar it's
probably the biggest Miss in my career
in in currency trades I missed the last
nine months run up in the dollar I just
couldn't bring myself down Joe Biden and
Jerome Powell I think now that on a
relative basis the tightening in the U.S
going forward will not be as much as as
the foreigners now that we've weaponized
the dollar
and you've got people like little uh uh
running around asking why we need to be
trading in US Dollars by the way it's
not a bad question historically we could
be trusted we had a rule of law a lot of
things
so about the only space I have any risk
on right now is it's in the US dollar
don't run out in short dollars I could
change my mind in a week but that's
where I am right now and I'm also along
gold obviously for the same reasons if
druck is right then we are in for a
bumpy road we'll continue to get that
devaluation of the dollar we'll continue
to get all sorts of Chaos in financial
markets because of a recession and none
of that is addressing the bank issue
the banks are on all sorts of uneven
unsteady ground and then we get hit with
a recession which causes the central
bank to Pivot that my friends is utter
chaos in economic terms
stay safe out there keep your head on a
swivel keep paying attention to what's
going on with the banks with the fed and
with a potential recession
we are an unprecedented Waters I think
we'll get to the other side and be just
fine but between here and the other side
I have no clue what's going to happen
and I just hope that a lot of people
don't end up getting hurt